hot breath what do you find
provokes that gut laughter that we all
like seek what have you found is there
like a specific type of joke
or like is it the more personal material
like what
what gets the audience in the gut like
that
i've seen guys do it with like a motion
i've seen it i've seen guys do like
different kinds where people go yeah
i've been in that situation before
and that's a hilarious take and it's
hilarious because
they've gone through they've gone
through the same thing
and then the the comic is taking such a
twist on it
and it's it hurts they're they're taking
their past
thoughts and behavior and then they're
listening to this guy spin
on it and it's and it it makes them
laugh it's
it's making them gut laugh because
they've been in that situation
they've never thought of it that way so
it's something familiar
and that they can connect to and then
the turn on it
that the cons unique take on it really
affects them it affects them like in an
emotional way okay and then i've seen
guys just
do it with straight i've seen you guys
do it with straight jokes just like
just kill with straight jokes also so
you know i guess there's multiple
there's multiple ways of getting that
gut left
but uh the important thing is like
recognizing it
recognizing just do you do your style of
what you're doing
but then recognizing when it's a gut
laughing and recognizing when people are
just laughing
or what what the level of it is it's
important that's important